you're giving mama jar off the big  center so what angle 11 blunder 18 1  bishop is oh my words  what after  this is this is incredible you remember  i even showed that hang on bishop ac  weakens the  whoa  whoa look at his face  that's incredible  i've never seen  peter is this true i mean tell me this  is a joke no this is is that a ball of  jack daniels he's just got there maybe  he needs it you know this is  yeah  he's literally just blunted into a mate  in one  um  i  i can't believe that i mean his position  i think peter was horrible anyway but  you you  he had he had he had a thing for a  couple of minutes here  and uh five minutes for five minutes  five minutes yeah five minutes  i don't think i've ever i don't think  i've ever seen such a strong player  blunder mate in one like that it made